jumping in for the first thing is this
this had to be ridiculously fun for you
to make this movie or am I wrong about
this it was what a chore now this was so
fun you know I I had no pressure on me
I'm just playing this CGI character
chrisandtess I have to you know step
into the shoes of Will Smith and Tommy
Lee Jones that's a lot to live up to I
didn't ever do that I just showed up had
fun goofed around with them went home
this was a blast how much you're
obviously very funny how much is
everything scripted for you and how much
is it sort of like when they cast you
they're sort of expecting you to add a
little bit of what you bring to the
table so the script was very funny and
Pawnee was very funny in the script but
they sort of asked me you know we sort
of worked together to figure out the
specific nature of this guy his points
of view on everything and then we we did
what was scripted and then we did
improvise a lot we always were trying to
find stuff and chrisandtess I loved that
too so even their lines he was just
always trying to see what we would come
up with that you know felt in the moment
completely um I have a few random
questions I'm gonna throw at you what TV
show would you love to guest star on
what TV show what I'd have to guess
darlin well Always Sunny in Philadelphia
I really really love and I even know
those guys know how you know I keep
being like hey so this year is that
gonna be like a Pakistani guy who comes
in for an episode and they're like no
not really no plans for that so I would
love to be on that show what else
there's a couple I love the good place
that's a show I really love I'd love to
be on that there was another one but I
can't think of it right now do you
remember your first movie or TV show
crush my first movie or TV show crush I
think you know it might have been
Sigourney Weaver in ghostbusters that's
one of the first ones I remember or
maybe Sigourney Weaver in alien
or I think it might have been Sigourney
Weaver instead yeah I'm sensing a trend
yeah it's the trend is to go near Weaver
wait you by the way you can't go wrong
with aliens in any way shape or form no
at all what movie have you seen the most
it's either Four Weddings and a funeral
or Casablanca I think it's for wedding
the funeral all the first Ninja Turtles
movie those are the three inside their
teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles because
there was a summer where I watch it
every day Four Weddings and a funeral or
Casablanca it's one of those it's
interesting to remix yeah I think it's
different stages of my life actually
Casablanca and for weddings are not as
dissimilar as the same Ninja Turtles is
very different I I've heard a little bit
um what was the last Easter Raphael is
in a coma in a bathtub for like a
picture that movie
nobody talks about it they're like ah
he's gonna come let's put him in a
bathtub see what happens he'll come
around by the way it's amazing that the
tmn that those characters have
transcended generations I think God we
can't get rid of them it's not that I
wanted right I love I love Donatello the
gang but I mean there really haven't
been around um I already got to go but
just real quick what was the last thing
you were really obsessed with flea bag I
just watched them to season a flea bag
and it blew me away and it made me
excited and upset I understand thank you
so much for your time
rats on this I hope it's a huge